même la ministre la cacophonie que votre
gouvernement entretient autour des
retraites n'est pas de nature à rassurer
ceux qui ont travaillé toute leur vie et
qui aujourd'hui sont ajustements pour ne
pas lien scandaleusement présentés comme
des nantis les choix que vous avez fait
jusqu'ici sont claires les retraités
sont les boucs émissaires du nouveau
monde
vous avez décidé sciemment de baisser
leur pouvoir d'achat
homme d'un en désindexant les retraites
et en augmentant la csg qui pèsent sur
les pensions depuis votre arrivée les
retraités avec les classes moyennes sont
les grands perdants de votre politique
ils ont perdu près de 400 euros par an
par ménage
alors que les études publiées récemment
montrent que le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités ne cesse de décroître
vous installez une petite musique les
retraités en france son torero riche
trop peser trop privilégié c'est oublier
un peu vite qu'ils ont travaillé toute
leur vie et je peux vous assurer que
dans le nord ils ont travaillé dur
c'est oublier et ailleurs aussi vous
avez raison mais je témoigne de d'avoir
vu travailler particulièrement dur dans
le nord c'est oublier que le niveau des
cotisations retraites en france est
élevé c'est oublier que la vertu de
notre modèle social est justement de
permettre à nos anciens de vivre
décemment
alors madame la ministre la réforme des
retraites s'annonce et l'heure des choix
approche
allez vous persistez dans la direction
que vous avez choisi depuis le début du
quinquennat celui d'adp et construction
de notre modèle social et de la
paupérisation de nos retraités ou
allez-vous proposer une réforme qui
respecte ceux qui ont toujours eu droit
à une retraite sereine j'ai cru
comprendre madame la ministre que vous
hésitez sur le chemin des studios
les retraités manifestent aujourd'hui
leur mécontentement madame le ministre
éclairez nous
pour vous éclairer la parole est à la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice brigitte lherbier
je compte le gouvernement a entendu
aujourd'hui les demandes des retraités
modestes et je pense notamment à ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui pour améliorer
leur couverture santé par exemple nous
savons vous l'avez voter madame la
sénatrice nous avons mis en place une
couverture maladie couverture santé à un
euro par jour qui rentrera en vigueur
avant la fin de l'année 2019 nous avons
mis en place le 100% santé qui va
couvrir complètement les frais de
d'optique de prothèses dentaires et
d'audioprothèse et cela commence dès
cette année pour les prothèses auditives
et le dentaire nous avons fait le choix
de revaloriser drastiquement le minimum
vieillesse nous l'avons augmenté de 100
euros en l'espace de deux ans et demi
puisqu'il atteindra 903 euros au 1er
janvier 2020
c'est la plus grande revalorisation du
minimum vieillesse de ces dernières
années je pense que ce minimum
vieillesse que bénéficiera plus de
500000 personnes à plus de un demi
million de personnes
dès janvier 2020 nous avons aussi
entendu le désarroi de ceux qui se
plaignaient de l'augmentation de la csg
et nous sommes revenus vous le savez sur
l'augmentation du taux de csg pour les
retraités modestes qui ont une retraite
de moins de 2000 euros par mois et ses
retraités verront un remboursement du
trop perçu à partir de leurs versements
du 9 mai prochain avec eux donc un un
retour en arrière qui prendra en compte
le trop perçu à partir du 1er janvier
enfin à partir de l'année prochaine nous
travaillons vous le savez puisqu'il a
une demande dans le cadre du grand débat
à la revalorisation indexées sur
l'inflation des petites retraites
je pense que le débat est sur la table
j'en ai parlé ce matin à la radio
aujourd'hui tout est ouvert il nous
faudra faire des choix nous avons aussi
devant nous à couvrir un risque qui
concerne les retraités qui concerne les
personnes âgées qui le risque de la
dépendance qui inquiète énormément de
familles et nous aurons à trouver le
financement nécessaire pour prendre
en compte ce cette perte d'autonomie
donc ses choix ce sera évidemment nous
tous de l'effet je rajoute que les
retraités verront également une
diminution de la taxe d'habitation comme
tous les français donc les réformes sont
engagées le débat est devant vous je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]